we've no described what we call the
average velocity for a time interval
between when the runners started at time
T to a later time at t plus delta T and
we describe that as the component of the
displacement vector divided by the time
interval times a unit vector I hat
now what we like to ask a separate
question so our question now is what do
we mean by the velocity at some specific
time t1 now in order to understand that
let's just make a plot of the position
function so remember we called the
component of the position function X of
T so we're going to plot the component
of the position function with respect to
time now let's just say that the runners
started at the origin at time equals 0
so I can make some type of arbitrary
plot of that position function and let's
indicate in particular the time T 1 so
what this represents is X of T 1 and so
first I'd like to consider the interval
T 1 and T 1 plus some later time delta T
so let's make this T 1 plus delta T this
is the time delta T and up here we have
our position function of t 1 plus delta
T then for this time interval the
average velocity so for this particular
time interval the average represents
Delta x over delta T so it's just the
rise over run it's just the slope of
this straight line so for this
particular interval the average is the
slope of
the line shown here on the figure now
this is just an average velocity and now
we would like to do is shrink down our
interval delta-t so now let's make
another case where we shrink delta T and
let's again calculate the average
velocity so for instance suppose we have
a smaller delta T and we draw that line
then our average velocity represents
that slope and again we keep on taking a
limit so now we have another slope so we
have as one slope two slopes and now we
shrink again to a new delta T and you
can see that the slope is changing and
if we consider the limit as delta T goes
to 0 of this sequence of slopes then
what are we getting you can see
graphically that eventually we will get
to a line which is the slope of the
tangent line
at time t1 and so in this particular
case what we mean by the instantaneous
velocity V at time t1 is the limit as
Delta X goes to zero I had here where
we're taking this is the limit delta T
goes to zero of X at t1 plus Delta t
minus x1 of T divided by delta T and the
whole thing is a vector I have so what a
limit is is a sequence of numbers so we
take a fixed delta T we calculate the
slope we take a smaller delta T
calculate the slope and each time we do
that the slopes represent a sequence of
numbers and the limit of that sequence
you can see graphically is the slope of
the tangent line at time t1 and so what
we say is B of T 1 is the instantaneous
velocity at time T equals T 1 and that's
how we describe instantaneous velocity
at some specific time if we were now
being a little bit more general we could
just say that V at any time T is the
limit delta T goes to 0 Delta x over
delta T fall direction I had and the
only thing here is we're no longer
considering T 1 but an arbitrary time T
this quantity the limit is awkward to
write every time it has a name and
that's precisely what we call the
derivative of the position function
so our instantaneous velocity is the
time derivative of the position function
at any instant in time